How about some very simple vision.
Real so
we're not using a depth sensor anymore.
And this is about as simple a vision as,
as you can imagine.
So this is work that was
done by Frank Dellaert.
Who's a professor now at Georgia Tech,
in our robotics and vision group.
But in 1997,
he was like six years old it looks like.
No that's not Frank,
that's some kid at the museum.
Frank, Frank was doing
his PhD at the time.
He did something very cool, they said
you know, we've got this ceiling and
this ceiling has lights in it.
If we had a map of the lights
we should eventually be
able to figure out where we are by just
do we see light or don't we see light?
And the way that works is you had
a robot with a little camera that just
looked up, all right,
here's that little square.
And it would just see,
did I see something bright,
medium, or sort of dark?
Right?
It would, it could just
get a small number of sensor values,
or you could think of it as just
taking the total value as saying
about how bright is that spot?
Now to do that what I have to be able
to do is given being anywhere in here,
I have to know what is the probability
of getting that brightness in the image.
So, that's what this shows here.
That, if this was
actually the brightness,
this is the probability of
the brightness that I would see.
So the idea being if, if this is
the actual brightness of the state x of
the position, then this is the,
the likelihood of, of what I would see.
So for example,
suppose I'm under a light, okay?
So typically what I see is
this brightish patch here, and
this map is the likelihood of
getting that bright measurement at
these locations, and, and by the way in
this map, the black are the high points.
So you see each one of these lights?
So if I was actually under the lights,
the likelihood of seeing
something bright is high.
Otherwise, the likelihood of
seeing something bright is low.
Sort of near a light, I'm going to see
the, tend to see these gray things.
And when I'm far away from a light,
I'm going to see mostly darkness.
So those are, are p of z's given x.
And then, here's the thing running,
And it's a little hard to see,
you see all these red dots going?
And what's happening is the robot is
actually following this red line.
And it comes in, and it goes down.
And you'll notice, after a little while,
it knows exactly where it is.
Now it's going to turn off to the,
to the right over here somewhere.
And you see.
If it hangs out in a dark area for a
while, it's uncertainty grows because it
doesn't know exactly where it's moving
in that dark, in that dark area, okay?
So you're watching it and
it's doing some cool stuff.
What's interesting is, so
we have this map of the thing.
We can compare two things.
The robot knows the commands
that it gave to its wheels.
Okay?
So it knows how far it thinks it went.
It also knows how much
it thinks it turned.
You guys have an odometer in your car?
The odometer measures distance.
Odometry is when you measure how you
think you move based upon
how your wheels turned.
If we plot on this map where
the robot thinks it went based upon
it's wheels turning, we see something
that looks like this, okay?
And the reason we know that that's wrong
Is that these are areas that
it can't actually go through.
And you see it gets, sort of, right,
but then it, sort of, gets a little
confused, and it's going through parts
that it cant' actually go through.
When we add vision, and
why do I say add vision?
Well, we still use the odometry
as the deterministic part.
Make him jump for that thing, right?
So, the odometry says, well,
you moved a foot to the right.
Okay?
So, we add that.
That's our prediction part, so
we still use the odometry, but
then the measurement from
the vision improves our result.
Okay?
And that gets us the much better result.
And this is using essentially a camera
just looking at a little area and
saying am I bright or am I dark or
how, how bright is it and
I have a map of the ceiling.
So it's pretty cool.
Well done, Frank.